magnus carlsen this is his first world
championship match
[Applause]
the thing
everybody mentions first is obviously
world champion
and
i've started to
over the years like
identify with that more and more i mean
it's nice it's it's opening
it's opening uh some doors and it's a
position of great privilege but i don't
necessarily think it's very uh it's very
healthy that was huge pressure it was as
if the brain was just spinning instead
of working properly
i think that's something of the most
stressful that can be in sports to sit
there three weeks against the same
opponent and needing to have a good
sleep every night and it's so stressful
so much nerves i guess in the few years
before i became world champion
i was
most of the time i was pretty happy just
traveling playing tournaments and most
of the times i would be the best and i
was not that concerned with with the
world championship it changed a bit in
late 2012 and early 2013 but it was more
like uh well
let's just try and get it because
why not after i gained the title um the
situation became very different because
then i didn't want to i didn't want to
didn't want to lose it i didn't want
any others to to take the title away
from me then the first you have
something to achieve that you haven't
achieved before after that you either
repeat or
fall back down
and psychologically that's much more
difficult even if you know about
this phenomena and you think about it
and you prepare for it it's still for a
human being that's how it is basically
and i think you will see
comments from nearly all historical
world champion
having the same thoughts i'm not
necessarily that happy that i have it i
just i'm i just would be very unhappy to
to to not have it whether he's gonna
continue to play world championship
matches that's both dependent on being
qualified and willingness to play and
it's not for me to say
anything about the probabilities for
either of those two really i think
he should and he does take one
championship match at the time if he
were to lose a match
uh would he be able to not
try to qualify for the next one and like
kind of get revenge
i don't know
i'm not at all able to understand how
he's able to play under that pressure
and those conditions at all because
it's
it's inhumane if at some point he thinks
that it's so much worse thinking about
losing
then it is a joy winning or um
games or tournaments then he would just
quit playing i think
for how long do you see yourself
motivated now to keep defend your title
um
so
i think before every single
uh
before and after every single match
at least uh the last three it's been
it's been a real question of whether i'm
going to
uh going to play or i'm going to to play
the next
the next one also and
i would say that's
still still the
the same
i will most probably play in 2021
and
if i if i were to win i have no idea
whether i would play the next one
[Music]
you